We just finished looking at the groom component.
In this section, we will delve into the LOD sync component and then take a close look
at the metahuman component.
So let's jump into Unreal Engine and begin by exploring the LOD sync component.
Each of the components that make up a metahuman use different types of geometry and different
numbers of LODs.
If we look at the face skeletal mesh, the face and groom components will have up to
eight individual LODs.
If we set this to LOD 7, we can see a change in the grooms, the geometry, and skeleton.
Now if we take a look at the body skeletal mesh, over here we will have up to four LODs.
When we switch this to LOD 4, we can see a change in the skeletal mesh geometry and a
more simplified skeleton without correctives.
Now let's return to our metahuman blueprint.
Over here, the LOD sync component is what manages and synchronizes the LODs across all
of the different metahuman components so that they switch at the same time.
As we saw, the face and groom components have up to eight individual LODs.
The body, feet, legs, and torso have up to four individual LODs.
This means that for every two LOD quality changes on the face and grooms, there will
be one LOD quality change for the body, feet, legs, and torso.
In the details panel of the LOD sync component, the custom LOD mapping option is where you
can control how LODs switch.
We can see how this is set up for the body component.
For every two LOD quality changes, the body will switch from LOD 0 to LOD 1 and so on.
The number of LOD settings is where you can set the maximum number of LODs that are available.
By default, it will be set to eight.
The forced LOD setting is where we can set an LOD to be used by all metahuman components.
By default, this is set to negative one.
If for example we only want to use LOD 0, we would enter 0.
The minimum LOD setting is where you can set the minimum LOD.
So for example, if you set this for LOD 2 to be the minimum LOD when synchronizing components,
LOD 0 and 1 will be skipped.
Now before we move on, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
The LOD sync component is responsible for managing and synchronizing the LODs across
the different metahuman blueprint components so that they switch at the same time.
As we just saw, the face and grooms have up to eight individual LODs.
The body, feet, legs, and torso have up to four.
We saw in the custom LOD mapping that for every two LOD quality changes on the face
and grooms, there is only one LOD quality change for the body, feet, legs, and torso.
In the LOD sync settings, you can set the maximum number of available LODs in the number
of LODs setting.
By default, this is set to eight.
You can also set an LOD to be used across all metahuman components with the forced LOD
setting.
And by default, this is set to negative one.
Now let's return to Unreal Engine and take a look at the metahuman component.
The metahuman component was added in engine version 5.4.
This allows us to turn on and off animation features for each LOD.
We can control at what LOD certain things are evaluated at, such as the body and neck
correctives, rig logic, procedurally running control rigs, and rigid body simulation.
In the body parts settings, which apply to the torso, legs, and feet, we can control
the maximum LOD level that the procedural control rig and rigid body simulation is applied
to the physics asset that has been assigned.
For example, for the control rig LOD threshold setting of the hoodie, if we set this to two,
physics simulation will only be enabled for LOD zero, one, and two on this body part with
control rig.
For the rigid body LOD threshold, we can control the maximum level to simulate the
rigid bodies of the hoodie.
If we were to set this to one, the hoodie will simulate for LOD zero and one.
Another thing we can do is to enable and disable body and neck correctives.
Enemies are responsible for preserving the volume of the skin, resulting in higher quality
animations and more believable movement.
However, this comes at the cost of performance.
By default, the body and neck correctives and the neck procedural control rig are only
applied at LOD zero.
If we disable the body and neck correctives, we will see a boost in performance at the
cost of quality.
For the neck corrective LOD threshold, we can control the maximum level where these
post drivers are evaluated.
We can also control the maximum level where the neck procedural control rig is evaluated.
For example, if we change that value to two, correctives will be evaluated for LOD zero,
one, and two.
The face animation LOD threshold controls the maximum LOD level where rig logic is evaluated.
If we change the threshold to two, rig logic will be evaluated at LOD zero, one, and two.
When this is set to negative one, rig logic will always be evaluated and will disable
LODing, which results in a boost in quality but lower performance.
Now let's do a quick review of the metahuman component before we move on.
The metahuman component allows us to enable and disable animation features for each LOD.
We can control the LOD level we want correctives, rig logic, procedurally running control rigs,
and rigid body simulation to be evaluated at.
When correctives are enabled, the volume of the skin is preserved during animation at
the expense of performance.
Disabling correctives will result in a boost in performance but at the cost of quality.
For clothing with physics properties such as the hoodie sweater, we can set the maximum
LOD level we want physics to be simulated for this asset using the rigid body LOD threshold
setting.
We can also set the maximum LOD we want physics to be simulated when used with control rig
by adjusting the control rig LOD threshold.
For example, if we set this to two, simulation will be enabled for LOD zero, one, and two.
The facial animation LOD threshold allows us to set the maximum LOD level for rig logic
to be evaluated.
Setting this to zero or one will mean that rig logic will only be evaluated at this LOD
level.
The LOD threshold for the neck correctives and neck procedural control rig controls the
maximum LOD at which correctives are evaluated.
Deactivating these or setting the LOD threshold to a lower value will result in a boost in
performance but at the expense of quality.
Now let's move on to uncover what role rig logic and the metahuman animation blueprints
have on quality and performance.